washington state has a new incentive to
get the wuflu vaccine
the state's liquor and cannabis board
yes that's a thing
is now offering marijuana dispensaries
the opportunity
to host vaccination clinics in their
stores and to give a free
joint to customers who take the shot
they are going to incentivize you to get
a shot that ostensibly protects against
a respiratory virus by giving you a
recreational drug
that rips up your lungs but the plan
raises
other questions if the vaccine is so
great
why do governments need to bribe people
with money
and food and drugs to take it
if the virus is so dangerous why aren't
people crawling over
one another to get the vaccine some new
moves by the public health bureaucracy
raise even more questions about what
we've been told and some top politicians
are finally calling for dr fauci to be
fired
now there is some uncharacteristically
good news out of the supreme court
and out of the pentagon that's great but
don't fool yourself
the left just proved it still has all
the power
they gotta bribe you with drugs and
cheeseburgers and french fries
and millions of dollars through those
covid lotteries
to take this vaccine that's apparently
so great that
nobody wants to take it because of the
virus that is so
so dangerous that everyone's just going
around
with their normal lives and many people
who have the virus don't even know they
have it
does that make a lot of sense to you
listen i'm just as shocked as you are
that we are still
on youtube but there's a fair chance
you're not getting notifications right
now
the way to get notifications or to even
have a chance to get notifications
you ring that bell you like you
subscribe you will get the notifications
then by the way head on over
to the audio podcast apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher wherever
you get your podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe we'll see you there